[Music]
sometimes
unfortunately
our hypothetical scenarios
get real
today
we want to show you the footage filmed
and shared
by ukrainians who are under attack from
russian forces
this
is happening today
please turn your sound on
[Music]
on february 24th
russian president vladimir putin started
a war
if you were in kiev that day
you'd have woken up at 5am
to the sound of explosions and
shattering windows
russia turned kiev into this
they hit strategic targets and
residential buildings
they didn't just hit kiev
but also many other cities across
ukraine
the following clip you see might be
disturbing
[Music]
this happened in kiev on day two of the
war
this is the driver of the vehicle
luckily he survived being run over by a
tank
ukrainians are fighting for their
country and their freedom
they've asked nato to help protect
ukrainian airspace and to cut russia off
of the swift global banking transfer
system
you can help the people of ukraine by
sharing this video
and by supporting rallies in your city
ukraine is standing up for the whole
world right now
it's time to stand with them
[Music]